gap inc unis c'est cool tu nies bâti
j'avais fait une rime à mesure c'est pas
mal j'ai tourné dans le bayou t'aime
bien mais c'est l'appartement le wiiw
c'est le tien non c'est bien voilà on se
met à mr d'amis était chaude ashton la
bague ou même sauté dessus
mais ces vitesses et accumulé lui sauter
dessus tu plaisantes j'étais chez toi
elle a appelé de resto la quitter pascal
t'aime tu m'aimes bien voir des stars
toi bon alors d'autres problèmes toi que
j'ai eus syrie
ils ne sont pas me gêne pas de quoi tu
me parles le projet de quoi pendant les
35 heures oui il ya et vous avez fait la
nuit et ça m'a donné une idée j'ai
envoyé un message à cyril jeune est
ainsi réduite en supplie avec jean
mignon pourrait être trop bien donc une
antenne livre où on peut parler de
l'etei depuis on peut faire ce qu'on
veut quoi et il m'a dit vas-y tu une
super bonne idée faut trouver un an
d'émissions mais juste un vrai projet je
te jure j'ai démontré une singulière de
civils où je vais enfin le ive c'est à
dire se retrouvant ses shows mais tu
n'es tu pas que ce soit des compétences
je n'ai pas dire on t'aime parce que
c'est sait comment ça marche et j'étais
à cyril truc c'est leïla ça fait pas
l'entendre à moi donc jalousie mais elle
te dis quoi
badie et [ __ ] c'était trop chaud
pourquoi le service comme ça bien sûr et
écarter carrément et les gens vont au
qatar
c'est une figure il doit donc que
l'école et a appris à s'aimer dans le
coup mais t'es sérieux et donc du coup
pour l'émission voit la série lh veux
bien qu'on fasse des trucs un petit peu
voilà la nuit on peut tout faire
on peut aussi noter que notre dame est
urgent rien montré mais sans jamais
entrer médecin c'est pourquoi je dois
gérer si ce défaut je veux pas passer
pour un con si je dis qu'elle est grosse
bah ouais enfin vite fait toucher quand
tu vois que je me tapais en plateau
c'est ce qu'ils ont fait non je
redoutais série non event in fine au nom
qu'il a déjà vu comment tu fais pour pas
la moindre balle de break c'est pas
comme naturiste un excellent gens fous
de ce truc là et ces mêmes voisins
mais pour faire marrer tout excité mais
je la mettrais pas l'émission j'étais
que c'est un peu ou pas je dirais pas
que tu me laissent insensible aux gens
me ce qui se passe non mais vraiment tu
le dis à personne jamais cheikh mathieu
c'est ton je m'amuse c'est une
hystérique elle nous suit il me fait
suivre par ses potes par son frère et
tous mes qualités
alors regarde donc le chacha cdpa
chasser
cette charte du chat non en arrière en
arrière chargé d'aller cette photo
tourne tout en sauvegardant
non
m
ce terminal mais c'est vrai bien refaire
partie au pape est reparti et voila
voila je me suis pas vraiment étonné
voilà comme ça
nous arrive
et il voit leïla thueux pas un mot ouais
ok je t'envoie la mise au pas juste les
capotes thème viens pas vous à acheter
toute alerte
j'adore le voir c'est vrai qu'en rouge
je n'avais pas kiffer mélange hier
j'étais en vous je t'avais l'air tu fais
un coquin la chanteuse s'était kippour
bachand on sait que steve darcis et plus
rien même pas mature mais jamie green et
matthew jeu pour s'acheter de ne pas le
dire monsieur dans ma personne façon
assez réunir 100 parisien il m'a dit que
quand on avait couché sésame avant
patassé vrai ou pas arrêtes tu te dis ça
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui
jean michel est athée
je commence à être derrière cette étape
on se bat et du tablier comme ça c'est
pourquoi bah oui c'est pareil dans la
chambre bah voilà et pour chacun de ces
massages parce que j'ai acheté oui je
sais c'est bien sûr on a on a coupé on a
coupé la mais non on a coupé le reste
parce que sinon je vous écrirai pourquoi
c'était beaucoup trop chaud non c'est
pas vrai vous pensez tous ici que
capucine à piéger jean-michel mais en
fait non c'est jean-michel qu'elle
pesait quelque chose c'est jean michel
qui a péché commis alors attendez vous
allez voir la suite du magnéto parce
qu'il est fou mais justement j'aimerais
revenir sur deux trois petites choses
vous avez un petit zizi
c'est ce qu'elle a dit d'abord elle l'a
jamais vu non c'est n'importe quoi
voilà je veux montrer juste pour la
gloire de grande écoute on regarde une
émission pas marianne un tuyau mais
plongée avec capucine la vérité benjamin
castaldi
alors moi jamais j'arrête oh non non non
non comme la justice ouais vous avez pu
souffler les béninois mais j'ai appris
je ne sais pas ce ça me fait plaisir
d'imaginer vous auriez pu le faire
savourer non jamais de la vie
coiffure you peur de jean michel away
mais des ouf ne riez pas été rassurés ah
non non non mais je pensais pas qu'il
allait le faire
ah ouais bah oui mais lui il vous a
piégé en fait donc lui il était
dangereux parce que vous avez remarqué
quelque chose c'est que jean michel
parle beaucoup de sa meuf leïla oui
hélas hélas elle n'est pas commode c'est
parti suite du mahdi et où tu t'habilles
comme ça c'est pourquoi bah oui c'est
vrai à la chambre voilà et pour savoir
si ces massages faciles à acheter
oui je fais et je recherche isr
bah oui mais c'est un beau corps pour
qu'on allait la vidéo est en tête
j'avais jamais vu son tatouage
j'ai lu non toi le bandeau du plateau
reste qu'un massage à deux jeunes
comment comme ça ouais bah voilà pas
parfait nickel toi c'est quoi
on passe aux choses sérieuses
honnêtement tu aimes bien autorise pas
mais si j'avais pas envie je me serais
pas bien comme ça je ne vais pas appeler
serait pas en train de te masser soyez
pas mis en plus mais oui le filament
franchement tu m'as fait flipper
d'acheter un cadeau j'ai acheté mon ma
petite nuisette
j'arrive bébés nés ou jeu séculaire
je n'ai pas vu rentrer dans cet immeuble
il est pas là ni des palais où il débat
chez moi mais je fous là son laisse moi
tranquille est et celle exhaler
jeannette gérer plus bas alors il est
pas normal sur un tracé comme ça ne sera
pas chez moi comme ça laisse moi
tranquille n'est pas là bon ok il est
pas là il n'est pas là tu t'es
complètement trompé que je rentre chez
moi comme ça ouais bah désolé mais tu
comprends je les veux rentrer dans
l'immeuble
ça me fait péter un câble parce que
maintenant vu que il est connu avant
mais il a non mais tu sais quand tu peux
comprendre c'est ce genre de truc de
nana ou tu flippes parce que temps mais
qu'il est connu et étudie qui a toute l
année qui vont illustrer dessus en plus
à l'antenne ensemble enfin voilà quoi
je sais je ne sais pas quoi dire mais
non mais
et connais bien c'est son parfum c'est
son parfum je me sais est ce que parce
que c'est là tu peux t'asseoir seconde
vidéo hop est un [ __ ] sorte h les
cadets vous là qu'est ce que tu fous
torse nu non la sauvette sur la télé
mais ce n'est pas une fin mettez à poil
tu fermes ta [ __ ] et gv bézis acquis par
lvmh et les tapas mais l'autre mais le
premier trophée cela dit c'est toi qui a
chauffé trop basses chez toi tu veux
savoir à cacher vraiment à chauffer
c'est assez ringard chose mais ils sont
à semer ce chopper si nécessaire les
jamais soir exemple la tâche est charlie
ces voix là c'est oui c'est une caméra
cachée
ils voulaient me kane pour des question
j'ai failli oublier la claque est à
valréas tremblay vous vous amuserez
sciences day mais défendent il va péter
à vous
bravo quelle rigolade
franchement desquels pourrir jean-luc
reviendra sur différents moments tout à
l'heure un voilà dans les quatre tiers
parce qu'il a disséqué toutes les
séquences et on viendra bien sûr sur
deux présente juste moi je voudrais
revenir sur un truc c'est quand même la
claque est bon verre et vous verrez et
jean-luc on verra sur un truc très très
drôle à tout à l'heure à un autre regard
sur ce qui vient de se passer
ouais c'est ça vous a pas tout vu alors
on va juste revoir la claque comme ça
parce qu'elle n'était pas du tout prévu
à bord bon je vous dis franchement oui a
été prévu alors regardez
acclamé capucine croyez vous aviez
vraiment cru qui abat oui parce qu'en
fait c'est vous qui était censé arriver
à la place de leïla ouais c'est ça et de
là elle m'a parlé veille 1 il m'a dit ah
elle me suis et j'y vais c'est pas
possible
en fait c'était tellement gros comme
disait mathieu que j'étais loin de me
douter en même temps si je t'avais kent
avait tout fait pour ses besoins des
ménages riz seront la jeunesse à d'abord
c'est calme et vous quand même cas mais
vous faites votre quotidien
nabila vous auriez flipper vous aussi ah
ouais moi je serais parti en courant ah
ouais à médire ex bout car au bout
moi je me serais fait tuer par un mec
avant de serrer ouais parce qu'au départ
je vous raconte tout elle piège
en fait c'est caroline qui devait le
chauffage envie de mai et votre mac a
dit non ah oui rapport aux fantasmes et
où moi j'ai trouvé ça très drôle et sauf
que mon mec il a pris au premier degré
on a eu le scénario est tout au début il
a dit ok c'est drôle à moi je vais pas
dit comme ça c'est devenu mais c'est du
lien d'amour quoi quoi s'est engueulés
toute la nuit
il a produit parce qu'au début il me dit
ok je veux bien faire cette fait rire je
le fais pour toi moi je crois y perdre
au dessus bon c'est vrai que c'était
quand même assez aux étoiles de la tenue
machin est en fait c'est devenu un truc
premier degré il est reçu à l'elysée l'a
confondue avec votre mac à cause de nous
toute la nuit ah ouais c'est toute la
nuit tout d'alger a tellement j'ai dit
je peux pas faire ça je me fous je fais
un enfer sur terre qui s'est déjà
embrouillé avec son mac à cause de nous
à par davila
non non non je suis bien je vous pouvez
[ __ ] la merde dans les couples ça
devrait aller y en a je veux dire là
demain on va le prendre ou pas je vais
pas dit j'espère que son père a été bon
dans le dans le sol non je sois vous qui
regarde son père ce soir j'espère ce
mois ci nous regarde alors voilà je
voulais faire un petit bisou
oui voilà c'était que du jeu et
jean-michel en fait à piéger joue bien
c'est aux événements je me bats aussi
l'une des meilleures actions point la
volga
franchement oui a répété la célèbre
phrase vaut mieux et deux sur une bonne
affaire fait tout seul sur une mauvaise
merci cap aller coucher ma vie